pour finir sur une note d'humour madame
la ministre seniors la ministre le
catalan ciu jane hors ue 2008
le député des pyrénées orientales daniel
mach s'exprime en catalan il est
aussitôt rappelé à l'ordre par le
président de l'assemblée
c'est vrai madame la mersey les catalans
dans les institutions les
administrations dans les tribunaux les
langues régionales ne sont pas autorisés
pas reconnu par la république
leurs défenseurs lutte pourtant leur
faveur depuis des décennies il ya ici
une communauté une communauté qui vit
qui a une langue une culture et qui
demande à ce que cette langue et les
moyens de vivre l'espoir d'une
reconnaissance est permis en 1988
cette année là le conseil de l'europe
est d'abord la charte des langues
minoritaires
l'objectif sauvegarder mais aussi
promouvoir toutes langues minoritaires
maison novembre 92 alors que la majorité
des etats-membres signe le texte la
france s'abstient on utilise le français
est la langue de la république est le
français
c'est écrit dans l'article 2 de la
constitution française depuis juin 1992
soit quelques mois avant la charte
européenne
cet article se veut garant de la
cohésion nationale
il fait aussi barrage aux autres langues
qu'elle soit étrangère ou régionale
la modification de la constitution est
indispensable pour doter des langues
régionales d'un statut le premier
ministre lionel jospin veut s'y attaquer
en 1999
mais le président jacques chirac s'y
opposent cette même année la france
finit par signer la charte européenne
des langues minoritaires en sachant
qu'elle ne peut pas l'appliquer
la faute à l'article de déception et
voir humiliations parce que c'est un
mauvais coup quoi c'est dur de en mars
en campagne pour la présidentielle
françois hollande s'y engage
il appliquera la charte des langues
minoritaires s'il est élu et fera
modifier la constitution que nous ne
craignons rien pour la langue française
nous ratifierons aussi la charte des
langues régionales en 2013 son
gouvernement lance une révision
constitutionnelle
elle sera abandonnée faute d'une
majorité suffisante au parlement
à ce jour les langues régionales n'ont
toujours pas de statut dans la
république
[Musique]